I think a lot about the contrast
between banality and wonder,
between disengagement
and radiant ecstasy,
between being unaffected
by the here and now
and being absolutely
ravished emotionally by it.
And I think one of the
problems for human beings
is mental habits.
Once we create a
comfort zone, we rarely
step outside of
that comfort zone.
But the consequence of
that is a phenomenon
known as hedonic adaptation.
Over stimulation to
the same kind of thing,
the same stimuli again
and again and again,
renders said stimuli invisible.
Your brain has already
mapped it in its own head,
and you no longer literally
have to be engaged by that.
We have eyes, yet see
not, ears that hear not,
and hearts that neither
feel nor understand.
There's a great book called
The Wondering Brain that
says that one of the ways
that we elicit wonder
is by scrambling
the self temporarily
so that the world can seep in.
Henry Miller says
even a blade of grass,
when given proper
attention, becomes
an infinitely magnificent
world in itself.
Darwin said attention, if
sudden and close, graduates
in surprise, and this
into astonishment,
and this into
stupefied amazement.
That's what rapture is.
That's what illumination is.
That's what that sort of
infinite comprehending
awe that human
beings love so much.
And so how do we do that?
How do we mess with our
perceptual apparatus
in order to have the kind
of emotional and aesthetic
experience from life that
we render most meaningful?
Because we all know
those moments are there.
Those are the moments
that would make final cut.
Only in these moments
we experience a fresh,
the hardly bearable
ecstasy of different energy
exploding on our nerve endings.
This is the rhapsodic,
ecstatic, bursting forth
of awe that expands our
perceptual parameters
beyond all previous limits.
And we literally have to
reconfigure our mental models
of the world in
order to assimilate
the beauty of that download.
That is what it
means to be inspired.
The Greek root of the term means
to breathe in, to take it in.
We fit the universe
through our brains,
and it comes out in the form
of nothing less than poetry.
We have a responsibility to awe.